since their first appearance in a 1982
issue of Peter Parker the spectacular
spider-man the mysterious heroes known
as cloak and dagger have captivated
Marvel's true believers their unique and
complementary powers along with an
intriguing backstory and a compelling
romantic angle made them fan favorites
long before they hit TV but while
everybody knows about spider-man fewer
know the finer details of this
relatively obscure codependent superhero
duo if you're in the dark we'll shine a
light on the untold truth of
cloak-and-dagger dare to be a hero the
origin stories for cloak and dagger are
among the darker tales in spider-man's
corner of Marvel Comics the first flow
can dad cursed or esau teenage runaways
Tyrone Johnson and Tammy Bowen kidnapped
by a mob chemist and experimented on
with synthetic heroin they weren't the
first Runaways to be subjected to the
experiment but they were the first to
survive finding themselves after their
escape to be blessed and cursed with
bizarre powers cloak is able to banish
people to the dark dimension through a
portal within his float while dagger
produces shards of solid light which can
be used as weapons sealing their
partnership dagger also uses her powers
to provide cloak with spiritual
sustenance battling back a constant
hunger for life energy that he feels as
an embodiment of darkness if not for her
light cloak would need to sustain
himself with other living beings not an
ideal situation in their first
four-issue series in 1983 the duo work
together as a team sworn to in the drug
trade with their origin story steeped in
dramatic drug abuse plus cloaks
addictive need for daggers light it's
easy to read the duo as a reagan-era of
metaphor for drug abuse in the war on
narcotics considering how much opiate
use in America has increased since the
time they were introduced it's not a
plot that's aged well to a modern reader
their original mission mostly just looks
quaint yes to your life and when it
comes to drugs and alcohol just say no
Manta Lowe's marvel writer bill Mantlo
is one of the quirkier storytellers in
Marvel history the creator of cloak
dagger and also Rocket Raccoon he worked
on Marvel's toy tie-in titles like ROM
space night and micronauts before being
assigned to write for more popular
titles like The Incredible Hulk and
Peter Parker the spectacular spider-man
he conceived cloak and dagger as
supporting characters for the Peter
Parker series saying that the duo's
backstory and abilities can
I'm fully formed during a trip to Ellis
Island according to Manta Louis personal
essay on the characters the pair
embodied the feelings that he felt there
they came in the night when all was
silent in my mind was blank
they came completely conceived as to
their powers and attributes their origin
and motivation they embodied between
them all that fear and misery hunger and
longing that had haunted me on Ellis
Island the story Mantlo put together
after his trip was his first submission
for spectacular spider-man and it was
also he felt the best story he'd ever
written friendly neighbors of spider-man
after they escaped from death by
overdose cloak and dagger made it their
mission to seek deadly vengeance they
were successful despite the attempted
interference of the friendly
neighborhood wall-crawler who generally
frowns on the use of deadly force while
the duo were merciless and single-minded
in this first appearance yet also young
and naive qualities the sympathetic
spider-man understood all too well
making their turn as a pair of
spider-man antagonists extremely brief
what I'm trying to say is superhero
team-up thanks in part despite ease
friendship the wayward duo soon backed
off from their ruthless ways a little
tougher for cloak what with that need to
consume living beans and all with the
duo's introductory art being successful
cloak and dagger were soon spun off out
of the pages of spider-man to headline a
series of their own strange bedfellows
between 1987 and 88 cloak-and-dagger
stories were combined with dr. Strange's
in the pages of one series strange tales
the combined title was made as an effort
to boost sales for both series but oddly
strange tales didn't see the young
heroes teaming up with the sorcerer
supreme
instead each issue featured a
cloak-and-dagger story with its own
writing and art staff followed by a
Doctor Strange story from its own
separate creative team basically it was
two comics in one previous
cloak-and-dagger stories had been
extremely light on supervillains mainly
using run-of-the-mill drug dealers and
Street criminals for its antagonists but
strange tales started to flesh out a
more proper rogues gallery for the pair
including the demon nightmare and the
powerful magician mr. Gipp the combo
book served its purpose in keeping both
cloak-and-dagger and dr. strange above
water and popular consciousness cloak
and dagger split after issue 18 and
started their own title while Doctor
Strange got his own title after 19
issues ending the series the new mutates
a new comic series called the mutant
misadventures of cloak-and-dagger
debuted in 1988 and its title
inadvertently contributed to a debate
that would go on for years the question
of whether cloak-and-dagger are mutants
went back and forth among comic fans for
decades and a proper answer was only
recently offered the question of whether
the experimental drug that gave the
heroes their powers worked by triggering
latent human abilities was muddled for
years mutant misadventures seemed to
clear it up with its title alone and it
was mentioned more than once in the
first issue that it was indeed latent
mutant genes that allowed them to
survive the experiment and gave them
their powers but in a 2010
cloak-and-dagger one-shot they submit to
extensive DNA testing and are shocked to
discover that neither of them carry
mutant DNA and it was the experimental
drug in their own suffering that made
them what they are no matter how you
slice it that's pretty potent stuff the
teen angst Achilles heel cloak and
dagger are a formidable duo but if they
have one glaring weakness its how
vulnerable they are to having their
heads screwed with as teenage runaways
granted awesome powers they're both
pretty easily manipulated
but cloak in particular is kind of a
pushover powerful beams have a tendency
to try to take control of his power for
themselves with varying degrees of
success ranging from dagger has to talk
him down to superteam should probably
intervene dear diary my teen angst has a
body count notably the dream demon
nightmare has targeted cloaked twice
overwhelming him with darkness and
taking him under control the pair's
emotional instability and codependency
are their biggest weaknesses they may be
tough to overpower in a fight but
exploiting their teen angst has been an
effective strategy for many foes born
from despair as it turns out this was no
ordinary experimental drug it was
created with the help of a demonic being
named despair who feeds on human pain
and suffering through the spread of an
insidious addictive drug called D light
at the end of their nineteen issue 1990
series the demon revealed to the duo
that he helped create them imbuing
dagger and cloak with the light and dark
sides of his own power bizarrely that
made them both weaker and also made them
swap their powers he had intended to use
them as sort of misery batteries soaking
up their pain to feed on at his leisure
his identity and motives are perfectly
fitting for the characters with their
greatest nemesis turning out to be
living embodiment of their own teenage
angst why he looks so much like Skeletor
though your guess is as good as ours
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]